so we are asked question mark is roughly
equal to this squiggly equal sign right
over here this means roughly equal to so
not exactly equal to
44 times 78 so one way to think about it
is 44 times 78 is roughly equal to what
so they're really asking us to estimate
so i encourage you pause this video and
try to think through how you would
estimate what 44 times 78 is once again
you don't have to get it exactly you
just want to get it roughly and think
about which of these choices are closer
are closest to that estimation of yours
all right now let's work through it
together so for me the best way to
estimate is to think about hey can i
think of these numbers can i estimate
these numbers or think about what are
they roughly equal to and when i think
about what they're roughly equal to i
want to think about numbers that are
easy to multiply potentially in my head
so for example 44 is reasonably close to
40. so i could say that hey this is
approximately equal to or roughly equal
to
40 so that's my estimate of 44 or 44 is
roughly 40. and then 78 i could say hey
that's pretty close to 80 and so i could
say this is
roughly equal to 40 times 80.
and this is pretty straightforward some
of you might already recognize that 4
times 8 is 32 and then we have 4 tens
and then we have eight tens so it'd be
four times eight times ten twice but if
what i just said is confusing to you we
could think about it this way
forty times eighty is the same thing as
four times ten that's 40 times 8 times
10 that's 80. and this is equal to i'm
just going to switch the order here of
this multiplication which we can do this
is equal to 4 times 8 times 10 times 10.
4 times 8 is 32 10 times 10 is 100 so we
could say that this is equal to 32
hundreds or we could view that as
3200 which you could also view as 32
hundreds and so that is this choice
right over here now this isn't exactly
what 44 times 78 is but it's roughly and
this is useful sometimes in life you
just have to get a rough sense of what
something is going to be sometimes when
you even are trying to find this exact
product
you just want your brain wants to check
does that make sense let's say you went
through some process to figure out this
and you got and you you got some number
that is you know close to close to 20
and you're like wait wait no but roughly
when i think about 40 times 80 this
should be close to 3200 i must have done
something wrong so it also helps you
keep a check on yourself